how do you explain the difference
between centralization regulation or
decentralization or or deregulation if
you were to explain that to a sixth
grader
a decentralized asset is one that is so
diffused on so many different computers
in the hands of so many people that no
one person can change it or corrupt it
means Bill Gates can't corrupt it the
head of the SEC can't corrupt it a
president of you know the head of Russia
or the us or the UAE can't corrupt it no
company can corrupt it if I own a
billion dollars of it I can't corrupt it
and so a decentralized asset is like a
it's like the cold virus
you get the cold a billionaire gets the
cold you both have the same cold the
billionaire doesn't duck the cold you
can't give the billionaire a different
coal than you got it is just a force of
nature we all equally share and you know
benefit and suffer if I give you an
orange and I give a billionaire an
orange and I give the head of Russia and
orange you all got the same orange
nobody gets a better deal that is a
decentralized commodity a centralized
asset
it's like Apple stock you know if Tim
Cook gets up and decides to print 10
million more shares of Apple stock he
could
if Tim Cook decides to cut the price of
the iPhone to zero like Mark Zuckerberg
here's an example of the risk of owning
a security Zuckerberg decides that
Facebook should be meta
and the price of the stock Falls by 65
percent and and is it legal and ethical
for him to do it yeah
if you bought Facebook stock you read
the report you know he controls the
company you know he's the CEO you know
he could do it you can complain about it
but that was the risk you had going into
it
you're never going to wake up and be
holding an orange in your hand and find
out that some dude that hates you around
the world cast a magic spell and made
two-thirds of your orange disappear you
see
so one of these things is a natural
asset the other is an artificial asset
Securities are man-made assets
Commodities are nature created assets
they both come with risks
but when you buy a bar of gold and you
lose money it's not because the CEO of
gold Corp
made the gold copper
right and then made it like rot away on
you right goal it is what it is it's a
natural risk not and so that's why
Securities laws are structured such that
the liabilities of officers of companies
lie in the manipulation of the
securities
and and so if I was explaining it to a a
kid in school I would just say
a truly decentralized thing results in a
commodity where no one can corrupt it
and a centralized thing is a security
you're relying upon the effort of
somebody else and you have to trust them
and if you trust them you may get a
benefit
but you know just like trusting a bank
you know when you when you own someone's
fiat currency you trust the government
not to print more when you put your
money in a bank you trust the bank to
give their money back to you and when
you buy a stock you trust the CEO or the
management team not to destroy the
company through an aptitude or not to
dilute your stock by you know just
giving it all to themself secretly and
not telling you so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks right if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetaining it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bad toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]